this is the final day for Democratic
presidential candidates to qualify for
their next debate one week from today in
Los Angeles so far only seven candidates
have done so including South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete Budaj he is surging
in recent polling in Iowa he's in a
tight race with the top candidates and a
new poll in New Hampshire has him
leading the field they are of course the
first two states that will hold contests
to pick a nominee mayor people the
judges with us at the table this morning
mayor welcome thanks for being here good
to be with you
as we mentioned the house is set to vote
on impeachment of the president but the
president is expected to be acquitted in
the Senate so how do you think this
impeachment process is it helping or
hurting the Democratic race for
president I think it's a process of such
importance that you can't think about it
in terms of the politics sometimes
there's a situation so grave
constitutionally that you just have to
let it play out and then let the chips
fall where they may politically now when
I'm on the ground talking to voters in
places like Iowa South Carolina and
in-between I'm mostly hearing voters
asking this basic question of their
presidential candidates and it's this
how is my life going to be different if
you're president versus one of the
others and our message is about
preparing for an America after Trump
because by definition we're running not
only to be the nominee capable of
defeating Donald Trump but also being
ready to lead the era that is coming
next and we're going to have huge
challenges as a country both in terms of
policy making sure that we have health
care and an economy that works for all
of us and just in terms of unifying a
country that will be even more divided
on that day than it is today well in
order to do that first you have to get
the nomination so you can you can get an
office and make the changes you would
like to make and one of the sticking
points that people always say about you
is it difficulty in attracting black
voters you know and no candidate in
recent history is one without the
support of black voters why do you think
you're doing so poorly with the black
voters and what are you doing to change
that well we're reaching out to
african-american voters in particular in
the South where what we're seeing is
there's no more negative view of me but
a lot more folks say they don't know me
to begin with but how do you think you
got in this position to begin with me
repeating well what I'm finding is a lot
of voters in particular black voters I
talk to feel like they've not only been
often abused by the Republican Party but
sometimes taken for granted by the
Democratic Party and that means when you
show up and you're new on the scene as
opposed to having had years or even
decades in Washington you've got a lot
more work to do to earn that trust when
you talk in particular to
african-american women who have been the
backbone of the party in so many ways
really propelled a lot of our most
importantly bloating a key vote in
critical and it's a lot of skepticism of
the new person showing up but I welcome
that challenge because it's critically
important not only to win but to deserve
to win so wait when you talk to those
black voters and I think you're at 2%
right now in South Carolina see when you
have those conversations to get that 2%
up the 20% and beyond what can you say
in your record what can you point to to
say look I've helped the lives of black
Americans well what I point to is the
things that we've done in our community
that line up with the things I'm
proposing we do as a country so for
example we've got a lot of challenges
around housing right now as a country
we've got families that have been
redlined generationally into certain
neighborhoods once those neighborhoods
become desirable they get gentrified
right back out of them in South Bend I
directed resources to low-income and
mainly minority neighborhoods to improve
the quality of life there when we look
at the the national picture for
african-americans we see a wealth gap
and an income gap we need economic
empowerment at home we work to make sure
that we reduced unemployment reduced
poverty and had a lot to show for it so
part of it's about my record part of
it's about my plans but what I'm finding
there's a lot of times when I'm speaking
to voters before they want to hear
anything about your plans they want to
know what's in your heart and so the
biggest thing I have to convey is how my
makeup my being my faith teaches me my
responsibility to make sure that I'm
lifting up those who have so often been
excluded in our society and our politics
many of your Democratic rivals are not
taking big dollar donations why have you
not adopted the same policy we are
getting ready for the fight of our lives
we're going up against Donald Trump and
his allies who I believe
raised a hundred and twenty-five million
dollars just in the last quarter in
order to stay in power if somebody wants
to contribute to my campaign to support
us in taking on Donald Trump then we're
gonna need to bring everything we've got
to that fight
I have 700,000 donors I believe the
average donation to my campaign is $32
and I'm proud at least the name of your
big bun lers when do you intend to do
that so we've already done it I think
for the first and second quarter they're
putting together the information for the
third quarter and remember every single
contribution of my campaign is made
public the person who made it what they
do for a living and this is about making
sure that we are ready to compete but I
only I make exactly one promise to
anybody who makes a donation to the
campaign whether they come to an event
to see me speak or whether they go to
Pete for america.com and send in five
bucks and the promise is this I'm going
to take that contribution and use it to
defeat Donald Trump well I know you've
heard Mayor Bloomberg who's gotten in
the race who told us all the other day
that all the candidates who are running
so far Donald Trump would eat them up
that includes you mayor Pete so your
response to that here's what its gonna
take to beat Donald Trump first of all
it would be a good idea to have somebody
who's actually from the industrial
Midwest the kinds of communities that
this president appealed to secondly I
think it might be a good idea to have
somebody who's actually from the
middle-class I may be the only person on
that debate stage who's not a
millionaire and I think it's really
important right now to have somebody who
was a little more in touch with the
day-to-day lives and concerns of
Americans and I'm also welcoming the
opportunity to challenge this
president's military chest-thumping this
president thinking that it's somehow
pro-military to overthrow military
justice in order to benefit a war
criminal I'm happy to talk about and
debate the fact that I was packing my
bags for Afghanistan while he was
working on season seven of Celebrity
Apprentice you have talked about a new
generation of leadership and if you
became president you would be the
youngest president in history and yet
you don't have a majority of young
voters in this country according to
polls is there a way in which you're out
of touch with your own generation no but
it is certainly the case that often
younger candidates tend to attract more
support from
older voters but we are building a
coalition that's gonna draw voters from
every part of this country now it's
certainly at three and four percent
among people under the age of 44 in
South Carolina it's almost as bad as
minority voters what explains that gap
look there's gonna be a continued
process to earn support across the
coalition but it's certainly the case
that many of the younger voters are more
attracted to for example you know the
Sanders campaign definitely has more
young voters I was a big fan of Bernie
Sanders when I was 18 years old it's
also the case that we are pulling
together a coalition to talk about
issues like climate to act on issues
like climate and guns and the economy
that the longer you're planning to be
here the more you have at stake and
young voters have to mobilize in a way
that hasn't happened before if we're
going to be able to defeat this would
you forgive all student debt like some
of your rivals no I'm not gonna promise
and being just wave away all student
debt now what I will say and again this
is personal for me because one of the
reasons why I am literally the least
wealthy candidate running for president
right now is that I'm married to a
teacher as a household we've got six
figures student debt right now so I get
it
but that doesn't mean I can just say
we're gonna make it all go away and it's
all free now what we should do is expand
programs for debt relief through public
service we should contemplate removing
the student debt of those for-profit
shady colleges that would never have
stood up to scrutiny in the Department
of Education to begin with and make
college more affordable on the front end
so what I'm proposing is that we make
college tuition free public college for
the first 80% of Americans if you're
between that 80 and 90 percent over a
hundred thousand dollars it will be a
sliding scale if you're fortunate enough
to be in that top 10 percent I still
wish you well but I think you ought to
pay your own tuition and that's just a
difference I have with some of the other
candidates you'd think that even the
child of a billionaire should have their
college tuition debt paid compare their
college tuition paid completely by
taxpayers let's talk about your other
candidates because I know they're saying
we got to go if you couldn't vote for
yourself who would you vote for you know
I'm not going to name check any of my
competitors I will say go ahead go ahead
Murphy give us a name I will say that
I'm proud right in by the way I
part of this field yeah this is an
extraordinary field
talented diverse we've been at it for
almost a year now when you look at a VP
candidate are you looking for someone
that has that's maybe a little older and
has more experience or does that not
factor into your thinking at this time
the number one criterion for a VP
candidate is this is a very grave
decision we need someone old to get a
young vote
I mean look before you even get to the
voting I mean kidding apart you know
this is somebody who would have to take
over the country exactly the event that
I'm killed or unable to serve and it's
the one decision you make as a candidate
that's really a presidential decision
because the whole country has to live
with it having said that whether it's
the VP or the cabinet I also believe
that balance is very important diversity
is extremely important it's one of the
reasons I've committed to having a
cabinet that's at least 50 percent women
not only because it's the right thing to
do but because we'll make better
decisions and I think that balance is
crucial whenever you're building out
I've seen women make everything better I
have to say who's your favorite
Republican mayor Pete before you go well
you know we recently lost Dick Lugar
senator from Indiana a wonderful person
to Joyce I wish we had more like the
mayor thank you very much for being here
we're playing in the green room with Liz
oh thanks